hey hey the last thing we're going to
leave with
i had i had an argument maybe two days
ago with somebody
i just need you to let me know if you
agree or disagree
i said to somebody that
nobody in the history of hip-hop was
ever bigger
at their peak i'm not talking about
over their span of their career or
10-year run i'm talking about peak
okay then 50 cent is snoop dogg
i think i agree with that because before
you even said that i was thinking of the
artist in my head i was like you better
say 50 cent yeah
50. 50 and snoop doggy style error snoop
that like whatever year and a half when
he had this murder charge
and then 50 cent we haven't
anything like that as far as peak peak
yeah i would agree with that i think
that's a fact well
it's beautiful i mean me and you are
like [ __ ] well you know
our lists are definitely you know
there's a few disconnects but i think
we're pretty
we're pretty [ __ ] spot on with a lot
of opinions here that's true i think
if you're a rad fan it was 50 cent peak
like 2003
oh my gosh like oh my god
like what the [ __ ] he was standouts at
that time man
yo it's crazy people might be too young
for snoop dogg but with snoop doggy
style
1993 like come on man you just had to be
there
you had to be there and i was there but
i was like seven
i remember it yeah